thank you
[Music]
my Planet Iraqis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the Sands you can see Spice
in the air
The Outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all I've
known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy
Duncan can I trust you something yes
always you know that I've been having
dreams
about a girl on miraculous I don't know
what it means dreams make good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake
me up put on some muscle I did no
we are a house of tradies there is no
call we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile Gurney I am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to Iraqis our
citratees accepts
[Music]
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you never met Harkins before they're not
human they're brutal
the Duke's son sees too much
this is my dude kill them all
God in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
dad what if I'm not the future of House
of tradies
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing I ever
needed you to be
my son
if anything happens
will you protect Paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
thank you
again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]